so when we were on the air together we
were on the air for
when did we first get on eighteen three
years i think so it was close to three
years yeah
um we had some pretty crazy viral
moments
oh man yo do you remember i was just
talking about
like do you remember with little kim
yeah lil kim was not [ __ ] with me
she was not [ __ ] with you she was not
[ __ ] here
yo lil kim was [ __ ] hot she was not
[ __ ] with you bro and i was thinking
about that i was like
i wonder i wonder like if people
like do people ever get over that [ __ ]
you've been in radio longer than me like
when people have a problem with you
check this out do they ever get over it
i think so because soulja boy came up
here
the other day and theo calls me first
right and he's like
hey man did you say something about
soulja boy in an interview
and i was like probably and he was like
because he he's like yo that's the white
boy used to be on there with the black
dude
yeah he said some [ __ ] about me in the
interview and i was like oh i don't
doubt it
yeah he came up remember he came on our
show no no but
after that i think and i've put up a
clip of the only thing i could find by
googling boulet kev soldier boy
was our interview with him and then like
me and draco talking about the big draco
thing dracula ruler
and so i was like it might have been
this but i don't [ __ ] know
and i was like he was like it's all good
but just know he's he's not [ __ ] with
you like that i was like i don't give a
[ __ ] i don't need to be friends with
anybody
soulja boy comes [ __ ] awesome
hangs out with my son we smoke weed
we're hanging out like
[ __ ] it was great like literally
couldn't have went better yeah and so
yeah like and look at the end of the day
sometimes we just got to do our job and
you and i wouldn't even do the kind of
[ __ ] like
like we wouldn't chase it we wouldn't
chase the got you moments
no no the only thing that the only thing
that stood out to me
was obviously the gates the kevin gates
situation was wild
but you know and i'm not making a
defense for him it was his first
interview he just got out of here
he just got out let me tell you
something what people don't realize is
that was a lot i had to deal with a lot
yeah a lot of people felt some type of
way a lot of people still feel some type
of way
but kevin gates comes to the radio
station
i go down to the lobby to grab him
and i've i've met kevin gates before but
he doesn't remember obviously
i'm like hey what's up boo like kev he's
like oh that's a good name kevin oh
yeah we booked up the same name right
shout out to uh
our guy from atlanta who's with him
dwight come up the elevator
[Music]
he comes in and he's like he needs the
room to pray yeah
so our guy eric fisher is stuck in the
room
with kevin gates while he's praying for
like 30 minutes
so eric's just sitting there and kevin
gates is in there alone praying you know
because he's muslim so he's praying
right
so i was like oh that's different we've
never had anyone come in and pray before
the interview
like okay whatever whatever floats your
boat or find your lost remote
whatever you gotta do bro yeah shout out
to allah you know what i'm saying
so we come in and do the interview and
automatically
he was just not into the interview no
at all at all he was not [ __ ] with us
whatsoever you he don't want to be there
and sometimes
we'll do those interviews with like man
this whole didn't want to be here like
why the [ __ ]
like by the way artists if you're going
to go do a [ __ ] interview like
and you don't want to do it don't do it
don't don't come because otherwise
anyway so then the moment happens where
you you touched his arm and yo don't
touch me
i feel like i'm being interrogated and
i'm just like bro it's an interview
in an interview we asked questions he
said yo how long we got to do this i
feel like i'm being interrogated in here
right
so whatever the case is the interview
finishes
and we wow
awkward bro so look this was interesting
about that
um you wasn't there because you know i
would go to the radio station
early right i just so happened to catch
a couple of people
from his camp at the radio station the
following day
i mean after after we after we put out
the interview right it's it's up it's
gone it's viral
i didn't like the fact we dropped it
that way they didn't like that we put we
kept it
we we don't edit our [ __ ] the [ __ ] we
were supposed to do right so
i caught uh a representative he's not
going to say his name
i call the representative of his coming
in the hallway at the right i'm like yo
what's up what you doing here yo man
i just i'm trying to see if we can get
the interview taken down dwight
i don't that sounds like dwight oh i'm
like yo
i'm like listen bro we not taking
nothing down yeah it's too late like
it's gone it's it's
i don't i'm not finna start my my
because this is like one of our first
interviews
i'm not going to start my radio career
editing interviews and taking [ __ ] out
and taking [ __ ] down like they wouldn't
ask the breakfast club to do that
so i'm like no so it's like well you
know we just highlight
at your boss see if we can i said all
right bet so i go right into our boss
office i sit down i'm like listen
i know they was he's like yeah they want
to take the interview down i said listen
bro i'm gonna be all the way hunting
with you
i'm i don't he's like well how do you
feel about it i don't want to take it
down
i said furthermore i'll be honest with
you if this is what we're going to be
doing like
doing the politics i'd rather not do
interviews moving forward
and he was like leave it up then so i
respect and it already went viral i
respect that though because
allowing your people to have input on
decisions like that shout out to doc doc
was always like that always like that
but they were so embarrassed by
how that [ __ ] went because it was his
first interview you know what i'm saying
but i'm like bro it's already up it's
out and also the crazy thing about it is
when the interview finished he hung out
with us for like an hour and a half and
played us his new album and literally
said
man i wish we would have started the
interview now because i [ __ ] with y'all
now
bro i [ __ ] you not kevin gates after
that interview
stayed at the radio station for a long
ass time playing at least an hour
hanging out playing uh music for us and
[ __ ] yeah
it wasn't weird or nothing it was like
as soon as the camera came on
it was weird so it was a lot of backlash